what is system integration i drag the
definition off of wikipedia basically it
says you take different applications
connect them together and create a
system out of
diverse applications
for the purposes of this talk today
system integration is the process of
transferring data between two unrelated
applications so we're not really talking
about apis which is another form of
integration we're talking about how do
you get data from system a to system b
yeah and for this talk we're going to
consider a more specific case where we
sending discrete entities in one
direction
i would use the word real time but for
people who use real-time linux and do
real-time processing
we for us real time is in the next five
seconds so it doesn't really count but
yeah it's soon enough for the kind of uh
interfaces we're talking about yeah
there are other kind of integrations you
can do um on the on the one side you
have the report dump where you take a
huge extract of data and you copy it
every day to another system and the
system does something with it the stuff
i'm going to be talking about today does
cover a lot of that as well
some of the issues you're going to face
are the same
the other
issue is where you've got something
that's more of a query service
your typical restful interface where you
have an api you connect to you set some
settings you pull down some data
that's another kind of integration you
also encounter similar issues to that
that i'm going to talk about today but
the problems are different enough that i
just want to focus on one particular
case
all right now i'm saying system
integration is hard and to quote jeremy
clarkson how hard can it be
well actually isn't that hard it
shouldn't be that hard it doesn't have
to be that hard
but give it time and we will find ways
to make it hard
and that's what i want to talk about
today
okay we have some unstated requirements
with synthetic grades this is from the
book of the blindingly obvious it's the
things we all
kind of understand and expect but never
really state out loud
first thing with system integration when
you're sending data you expect the
transfer to be reliable you send some
data from one side you expect it to
arrive on the other side
it's a requirement
we kind of expect everyone else to know
that but we don't often think about it
and the other thing is that the data
must be reliable yeah it's great that
the data got to the other side but if
it's turned into something else along
the way and lost all its meaning
what are we doing here why did we start
this exercise
so what we need to do is we need to
fulfill these two requirements among all
the other business requirements that we
have to have to fit the whole reason why
we're doing the integration in the first
place what are we trying to accomplish
so for today's presentation i've created
a fictitious logistics company
logistics is just a fancy way of saying
a mail delivery company
called peter's parcels
this business is about delivering actual
packages you order something from take a
lot it gets stuck on a van gets driven
halfway across the country and arrives
at your door maybe after stopping in
several depots along the way
for our example we are responsible for
the application that tracks where those
parcels are
okay so
we need to know this because we need to
know um that there is a parcel coming
that the driver has got to collect a
parcel when the parcel has been
delivered the web interface needs to
have information about
where the parcel is so when the client
logs in wants to know when the parcel is
going to be delivered we can give them
some idea
all right so that's the application
we're working on
but
the way the business is growing there's
a few other applications that we have to
deal with there's the customer web app
where the customers log on and they
request that are possibly delivered
where from where to how they're going to
pay they fill in all their details so
there's some web app out there
there's the driver app so when the
driver gets there they hand you that
device where you sign and it logs the
fact that the stuff was delivered so
that's a totally separate application
and then there's a fleet management
system we've teamed up with
matrix
they can give us a real-time location of
all our vehicles and where they are and
that's very important for us to know and
keep track of where those parcels are
because we know which which fan which
parcel is on
all right so great we want to put these
things get them all to work together
okay but unfortunately the customer web
app that's developed by a group of uh
snotty cs grads they don't really want
to talk to anyone they think node.js is
the only way to write any application
they're not really interested in your
problems the driver web app was written
by a long-timer in the industry
he really is angry that he didn't get to
implement his project in cobol
and it's just one guy working on it so
he also doesn't want to talk to you and
then the fleet management system isn't
even our application it's a third-party
application sitting somewhere across the
internet that we're connecting to that
provides us with information that we
need so we have even less control of
that sorry is that noise
i can hear buzzing okay all right
thanks
okay so
let's take our ideal world architecture
we can develop something this is when i
say ideal world this is actually more
current fashion because fashions over
the years have changed i have a few gray
hairs you may have noticed i have
encountered many ways to do this but
this is i believe the current trend in
how to develop an application what you
do is you have a restful web service
sitting in your application and the data
is pushed to you when someone creates an
order on the customer web that's things
hidden to you on the driver web when the
delivery happens you get a bit of data
to say deliveries happened and on the
fleet as you get real-time updates of uh
van locations
uh you could send to you and all pumps
into a restful web interface
so as we come to the python part of the
demo
and if i can just find my ubuntu virtual
machine here
oh this is not good okay there we go
see make sure these things are working
yeah yeah yeah go away
all right so what i have here and i'm
afraid i must apologize to make it
readable at the back i've bumped up the
font but i hope we're gonna be able to
see everything later this here is my
database this is just a simple web
service uh that receives um json
uh files that will be things but in
theory think of this as our database
we're writing stuff into our relational
database because we decided that was the
best way to store our information all
right
to go with this we now also have all our
other applications a whole architecture
so if we just start those up
okay so this here is our restful web
service you can watch that window here
and then these are our three
applications pushing data to us
all right like and i've just created a
whole bunch of random data that's being
pushed through for the purpose of the
presentation i'm just using very simple
data yeah but you can see here we're
busy creating orders uh here we have
deliveries going in and you notice all
these deliveries are happening in
johannesburg which will be important
later and the fleet tracking we just
have locations of let me just move that
out the way
we have locations of different vans
all right so there we go here are all
applications running and here's our
restful web service it's picking up this
information as it comes through
and it'll then get written to the
database this is a lot more impressive
on a big screen where you can see all of
these things running together but trust
me they all are all running together
okay
so we have this application working all
is good all our functionality works it's
great
unfortunately one day
we we hit a bit of a dose of reality our
restful web service goes down nothing to
do with us because we're really good at
what i do uh and unfortunately our
service provider forgot to add disks to
their virtual machine host and they
forgot to update the ssh keys and well
it's such a mess yeah things aren't
working for us so what is busy happening
now in the background you can see oops
sorry excuse me
so
what is happening now in the background
is these processes are busy failing
they're busy dying they're just dropping
all that information they're sending us
okay now remember we're dealing with
people who aren't particularly
interested
in the data that they're sending us
they're just doing it because someone
told them that they needed to send it to
us
so they don't really have any failover
mechanism they don't have any way to say
what was lost what was happening so now
we go through two weeks of hell
trying to reconstruct all this
information that was lost what was
delivered what was arrived you have to
do recons and pull information out of
different systems and it's it's a
complete mess
all right you don't don't want to do
things that way if you can avoid it
all right so that brings us to our first
problem
which i've decided to call enemies
because really those are
what they are in our world
first enemy is reality
as good as we design things as hard as
we work to make sure that everything
functions perfectly and nothing could go
wrong
things still will go wrong and when it
comes to integration that's an even
bigger problem because you now got
another team that you have to deal with
as well you've got a whole network
infrastructure you have to deal with
yeah i once worked on project actually
was last year
integrating
one system to another there were 11
different teams involved in the chain
that's the reason one of the reasons why
the project took about four years
so
just getting anyone to do anything and
then the next person on the chain had to
do their thing and the next person at
the chat so
the reality of your situation is
something you have to cater for yeah
don't just assume that because you've
done everything properly the integration
is going to work you need to cater for
the problems that may happen
and one of the best ways to solve that
is
generically store and forward which a
lot of us would know is queues
ibm mq if you're familiar with that for
this presentation i'll be using rabbitmq
which is great
and way better than ibm mq i think but
that's a different discussion
why do we want store and forward we're
actually adding a new component in the
whole system we're creating a more
complex system well actually
it might be more complex but it does one
job and it does it very well more
importantly with store and forward you
now have a record of all the messages
that gone through so if you have to
replay them and yours infrastructure
going around down is just one of your
problems another problem you can easily
have is you're getting the data but your
application is not writing the correct
data it's uh corrupting it so you
released a bug you put a bug into
production now you're corrupting your
data you've been doing it for the last
few days and no one noticed you want to
replay all those messages get everything
back into sync
guess what with store and forward we
actually have that we now have the
capability to take those messages replay
them
even if everything's working fine
outside something breaks we can go into
those messages and say what went wrong
we have a huge repository of debugging
and logging
in the actual messages that you can use
say what's changed what's happened all
right so this store and forward is
actually
quite an important thing if you're going
to build any kind of integration between
two systems especially where the
messages can't afford to be lost you're
gonna afford to lose messages yeah it's
maybe not so important but if you if you
can't afford to lose messages if it's
gonna take a long time to recover you
really really want to
have some way to keep those messages
right so you can see here i've got my
rabbitmq
dialog open i just want to show you that
it is there i'm not making it up
okay we've now developed a new
application
that's now slide two
and we're going to kick that off
and here's our q listener it's
essentially the same architecture as
before
yeah we now just have three applications
writing to a queue instead of writing to
json all that stuff is coming through
all good
we're happy right everything's working
no well now we've got another problem
and that problem is complexity
yeah
and this is kind of and this is not an
integration problem this is actually an
i.t problem but because you're now
dealing with two different systems it's
kind of an n squared complexity squared
problem you've now got more issues so
what you want to do is you want to keep
your application simple so instead of
having one listener that aggregates all
these messages and does everything
and why would you do that rather just
split them up
create multiple listeners that each does
a specific job well it's the unix
philosophy has worked well for unix it
can definitely work well for us rather
create an epic a little system a
subsystem that handles each one of those
interfaces don't put everything into one
big application when you have a problem
with one part of the application affects
now other parts of the application just
create a little system and by the way
this is another form of system
integration it's just at a more detailed
level
all right so
we can
go back to here we can kill this so i've
now killed our application but you'll
notice that the web interface is still
running uh we're still sending messages
through we're not processing them at the
moment but they are there
so our application didn't crash yeah
things are going to be a bit slow for a
while we're going to take a little while
to catch up but we've solved our first
problem
okay so
we've now created our next application
of course
we are adding more complexity by
splitting things up
and for a demo like this why would i do
this because this application doesn't
actually do anything but in the real
world where you've got to add a lot of
functionality a lot of logic to things
you actually want to have a separation
between the different applications that
do real work
okay
so you can see here i've got my fleet
tracking i've got my customer web
interface
and then here are the listeners
and if i'm not mistaken we should get an
error very shortly on one of these ah
there we go our customer listener it's
like wait hold on
something's going on here
we're busy getting stack tracers in our
feed
what's happening
all right while i was busy talking and
while we were busy working what happened
is the the people providing
excuse me
the people providing our data from the
customer interface decided they want to
add in an insurance
field this is our next enemy change
yeah stuff changes interfaces on static
the business changes they have new
requirements over time things happen so
they've added this new field into this
interface
and we because we decided we wanted to
do things properly we were
validating the interface we were making
sure we're only getting the fields we
expected everything was in the format we
expect yeah now this new stuff is going
to be everything's breaking we don't
actually need to know this insurance
stuff for now because that project is
scheduled for a sprint three months from
now so we're not really concerned about
it but suddenly our production system is
broken and not working
so to handle change
uh one of the things you want to do is
make sure that you don't create hard
bindings for the data that you're
getting be very permissive in what you
accept you obviously have to get the
data that you expect to be there but if
there's extra data it's not doing any
harm
unless it's like another 10 megabytes
per message
don't worry about it just let it come
through you can get to it when you need
it so don't put in
validating interfaces things that do
strong type checking on the data that
you're getting because it's just going
to cause you a lot of pain later just
lets things change with the flow and you
can update your side of the program
later
all right
so we've now gone and fixed this
application we now have a new
application that sorted this out
unfortunately while we were fixing that
production issue
another issue cropped up
we were told the company is now going
national we've just been delivering
stuff in johannesburg but now we do
bring stuff all over south africa and
that brings with a whole new set of
challenges yeah so like i said changes
the enemy
but
in this case the problem that we're
going to encounter is not change
yeah
we have our three applications again
i've now fixed the bug in the previous
application
now we're sending data through
and this is the one
you want to go look for the fleet
listener
okay
so here's our locations coming through
from the fleet application i remember
this is not our application this is
sitting offside somewhere but we're now
dealing with airlines because we're
shipping stuff by airplanes yeah and the
airlines don't really care about the gps
location they're not going to send you
that or rather the application that's
got this information
doesn't have enough format to use what
they have is they have the airport that
the airline departed from
yeah so your location is now not a geo
geographic coordinate it's actually the
name of a location you also notice that
the van id has changed is no longer just
a van number that we're getting it is
actually the registration number of an
aircraft because it's a totally
different kind of
fleet item we're tracking so it's a
totally different problem we're dealing
with
and this is for me one of the most
underrated problems in
yeah excuse me
no
[Music]
i need to get back to my presentation
there we go
this one is one of the most underrated
problems when it comes to integration
semantics we all understand that we get
a field that says location yeah it's a
location great but what does it actually
mean
you know where does that information
come from what does it imply
yeah so semantics are very important you
need to understand the data that you're
getting the details of what is embedded
in their data this is a very simple and
very very obvious example but a lot of
times it's not that obvious for example
that insurance price i gave you earlier
how do you know that's in rams
could it be in dollars it could be in
pounds we don't know
so you've got to understand your data
what you're getting
and when doing the system integration
it's very important to keep track of
that all right so you can see here this
is our new interface with all of these
bits and pieces
okay
finally the last enemy and i have no
application for this because
dimming is a bit tough
but yeah people
remember we're dealing with different
teams with different requirements
different agendas yeah
we have this nice beautiful diagram of
how system works but in reality it
actually looks like this
yeah you notice there's also an
accounting system that's crept in there
somewhere it's actually very important
in your life you just don't know why yet
yeah
so this is what really happens and this
is a people problem because everyone's
got their own thing that they're working
on that they're focusing on and they
don't tell you what they're doing until
the last minute suddenly becomes your
problem
so it's very important to understand
when you're doing integration especially
of this nature where it's different
teams you're working with that those
other teams have their own problems
their own priorities and you'll see
i've drawn our parcel tracker here as a
nice clean architecture but you can be
sure that the people in the customer web
see their nice clean architecture and
think ours looks like that squirrely
picture on the other side
because we also think the other team is
worse right it's just what we do
all right so to wrap things up what have
we learned today
principles of system integration
first thing is technology is only a
small part of the problem here we're all
developers we're programmers we like to
focus on the technology we want to talk
about yaml and xml and json and
do we do this via restful interface or
soap or we're going to use corber for
good no no no let's not do that
but yeah how what's the technology
that's going to send the data across
you know i used to do integration with
sockets it works it's slightly harder
than http and restful interfaces but
that's not really your problem so don't
get stuck down in the technology
get something that works stick with what
works for you yeah
next step is to focus on recovery not
availability i know when you've got a
web interface availability is be all in
or when the customer sees it goes down
it's a problem but this is happening
behind the scenes if something is
delayed by a minute they're probably not
really going to notice so your focus is
making sure that the data gets to the
end point eventually
and that you can get that data back all
right again there are restrictions
sometimes the data is not that important
you can lose it but then this wouldn't
be really the concept for this this talk
here the other thing of course is a
standards programming application keep
it simple don't be clever i see a lot of
people they've got all these interfaces
we should create a library that will
sort out all our problems except that
every problem is unique and then that
library just solves ends up solving 20
different unique problems and now you've
got a bigger problem in a library that
no one understands
so don't get too clever just keep the
interface simple
just write standard code solve the
problem immediately in front of you
because sure enough next week it's going
to be a different problem
okay another rule that i try and get
people to understand
source sends everything they have in a
form and format convenient for them the
problem you have here is ownership the
people receiving the data are the ones
who are going to own it the people
sending the data they've just fired and
forgotten it yeah so make it easy for
them i've been in projects where as the
person sending the data uh someone
customers says we need something that
matches this exact format in this exact
protocol with these exact fields in it
and sure enough two weeks later they
come back throw half of those away we're
redoing half the columns because we
realize we didn't get what we needed
yeah
don't fall for that just send them
everything that you've got and becomes
their problem to sort out same thing the
recipient is responsible for
interpreting the data making sense of it
and they need to own the problem because
at the end of the day the recipient is
the one who cares about what that data
means and they understand what their
system can do with the data
yeah
and then work with the other teams not
against them i have had
occasion where
two teams don't actually talk to each
other the only way anything happens is
when they escalate to their manager who
escalates to their manager and then
that manager goes and shouts at them and
something so the two teams actually
don't talk to each other at all talk to
each other get to know each other
understand each other's problems and
you'll find that grease is the wheels of
this integration things will work so
much better if you do that
and the last one is use a general
purpose programming language integration
is about solving general problems every
problem is unique every problem is
different there's a tendency to want to
create a tool that will uh solve all
your problems in a nice drag and drop
way and everything will just work and
the program is going to be involved
because the analysts can go off and they
just put some columns
never happens there's always some issue
and if you get some tool it's going to
solve 80 of your problem really well and
the other 20
is just going to be the banner of your
life you're going to spend 20 uh all
your time in production trying to fix
that 20
so rather just use a general programming
language and as you saw today with my
demo i just knocked that up in a few
hours you saw many applications i wrote
python works very well for integration
and i say i'm very happy with the way it
works so yes use python
all right
and then finally
remember there are no silver bullets in
this industry we tend to say ah
so-and-so said we must do things this
way this is the golden rule yeah but it
depends on what problem you're trying to
solve use common sense and break the
rules when you have to at least these
rules i've given you it's not really
pythonic because i know the golden rules
of python say almost exactly the
opposite but use common sense
figure out what problem you're trying to
solve and don't be too clear about it
just fix the issue at hand
and that's it if you want the code you
can mail me at the mail address i'm not
sure anyone wanted if you want to ask me
any questions
i'm